check out this map
of africa
[Music]
back then most of this continent had
been carved up
by european powers belgium had a big
swath of africa
right here where the modern day
democratic republic of the congo is
what belgium did in the congo is
shocking and hard to get your head
around
it's terrible in fact but belgium's
horrendous actions in the congo would
lead to
this i would definitely take the johnson
johnson vaccine the fda
has just approved a third vaccine let's
talk about the j and j the johnson and
johnson
the new johnson johnson vaccine is a
game changer
for the fight against coven 19. it is
cheaper
it can be shipped without having to be
frozen so it's way more
durable it's made of really
advanced sophisticated technology that
allows you to just get
one shot of it instead of the two doses
from the previous ones
version requires just one dose that's a
big deal when you're trying to vaccinate
literally billions of people
and so to understand how this vaccine
that is being rolled out by johnson
johnson a new jersey-based company
how that is connected to belgium in
the late 1800s in the congo basin
you have to understand the story of how
the sophisticated technology
was developed and by whom one man
at the conference of berlin walked away
with his own
private colony and showed what
colonialism looked like
at its very worst this date marked the
beginning of white penetration into the
black heart of africa
african sleeping sickness is caused by
the protozoan
parasites
[Music]
let me tell you a story of one of the
most
insane and horrendous versions of
european colonialism in africa
the 1880s and 90s were years of
terrifying upheaval
in africa it starts with this guy king
leopold ii
he's the king of belgium and by the way
this wasn't like 300 years ago this is
like
the mid to late 1800s belgium wasn't a
big player in the colonizing game not
like france and britain but
leopold sort of wanted to be he wanted
to be a big boy imperialist nation and
so he actually went to
spain and portugal whose empires were
sort of declining at the time
and offered to buy some of their
colonial possessions
they didn't agree so leopold decided to
take things into his own hands like
literally on his own he himself
privately
would create a colony for belgium okay
so quick pause
i just got an email from morningbrew
which is a thing that gets sent to my
inbox every morning
and is a digest of all of the news that
is happening but it's not just like the
sad depressing news it's like actually
interesting stuff
i don't like going down the rabbit hole
of trying to find out what news i should
be reading
so much of it is like noise and it
doesn't
help me understand the world morning bro
just gives me a digest
like a spark notes version oh it's
literally free
like there's no money involved here like
all you do is sign up
and it takes 15 seconds to sign up and
then you get this in your inbox
i feel like my mornings before this were
a little bit more scattered of like what
should i be reading this morning i'm not
going to listen to like a 20 minute
podcast
what can i sort of breeze through
morning brew just
aggregates it all into one place morning
brew sponsored this video
they don't have any sign up deal or
discount because it's literally free
like you pay zero money you just
go sign up the link is in my description
when you click that link it helps
support this channel
but it also gets you signed up for this
like very very good quality newsletter
i love it thank you morning for
sponsoring this video let's get back to
the story
and talk about what is going on in the
belgian congo
so leopold decided to take things into
his own hands
with his own money and his own army
he knew he would need some support for
this in terms of just like approval so
he created an organization that he
called
the international african society
leopold builds this organization and
says that it's meant to be a
research and philanthropy organization
with a mission to explore the world for
good and for
science but soon leopold would use this
organization to get his wish of being
a big boy colonizer it was 1884 when a
bunch of
the european and ottoman and american
powers who were colonizing africa got
together
and they decided that they needed some
sort of unifying policy of how they were
going to go into africa
how trade was going to work but they
wanted to work together as they
carved up the continent of africa
leopold gets up at this conference it
was in berlin
and he says listen i've got this
organization i would love to take this
organization of mine
and go and take over a huge swath of
central africa
and everyone's like you mean like
belgium's gonna go take over the congo
and he's like no
no not belgium me i'll do it with my own
money and the european powers are sort
of like
okay like how much harm can one guy in
his ngo do
going into congo so leopold gets his
dream
he gets international approval to go
take over a swath of africa that is 76
times larger than belgium he would call
his new
private colony the congo free state
well you know what happens next he
doesn't improve the lives of people that
was never his intention
instead his army quickly gains control
over the local population
and starts to use the locals to forcibly
extract
raw materials from the land of congo
mainly in rubber whose price was going
up during the industrial revolution
and in ivory he would put these quotas
on the local people that they had to get
a certain
amount of rubber and he would instruct
his army that if they didn't bring back
their quota that they were to go
remove their hands or limbs
this is everyone men women and children
who are being forced to work for king
leopold
and getting their limbs removed if they
don't meet the quota
so leopold starts extracting huge
amounts of wealth from the congo
and he uses this new money to build big
shiny things back in belgium
including this big beautiful park and
archways that
i used to bike past all the time when i
lived in belgium
or this beautiful train station in
central and twerp
wait a minute that train station looks
kind of familiar
yeah that's me showing henry the
clock tower in this train station i had
literally no
idea that this train station was built
on
the blood of people in the congo
okay so i know you're wondering what
does this terrible story have anything
to do with
vaccines and johnson johnson and the
pandemic
here goes buckle up so while leopold is
doing all this terrible stuff in the
late 1800s
almost the 1900s something happens in
neighboring
uganda an epidemic breaks out of this
mysterious disease
called sleeping sickness this is what
they called it they didn't really know
what it was but leopold catches wind of
the fact that there's a disease
spreading into the congo where he has
all these people and this giant
operation for wealth extraction
and he sort of freaks out he's like my
whole wealth operation might get wiped
out by this random epidemic
so he decides to put out a cash prize
for anyone who can go down
and devise a solution or a remedy to the
sleeping sickness
and then he starts to invest in actual
researchers and scientists to go down to
the congo and start studying tropical
diseases
to make sure that nothing catches him by
surprise
and wipes out his operation okay well
eventually the world catches wind of all
the terrible things that king leopold ii
is doing in the congo and they start to
mount pressure against
belgium the country and the actual
government of belgium to put an end to
this
it's 1908 and finally the belgian
government is like dude
stop like you're done and they
officially
take leopold out of the driver's seat
and they annex the congo for themselves
and the congo becomes an official
belgian colony for the first time but
these scientists and researchers
who leopold set up to start looking into
tropical diseases they didn't leave
they stayed they kept doing this work
and they actually started to make some
really important breakthroughs
they established an official state-run
organization called the prince leopold
institute for tropical medicines an
institution that was
leading the world in understanding
tropical medicines and
teaching research and study about this
topic
this organization was based permanently
in the congo
as well as in belgium fast forward a few
years and the congo
officially declares independence from
belgium with political independence from
belgium
control of the entire congo was turned
over to what is called the central congo
government
with headquarters in leopoldville by
this time
all of the holdovers from the king
leopold days are sort of gone
and now the institute for tropical
medicine is actually like a legitimate
institute that is doing groundbreaking
cutting-edge
research and study on all sorts of
pathologies and viruses and parasites
and
diseases in this region they're
basically leading the world
in tropical diseases and understanding
them they move their headquarters from
leopold's house in brussels to the city
of antwerp where that
beautiful but terrible train station is
and they sort of turn into like
a school like in like an institution
where they're training researchers to
then go out and work in the real world
okay so here's where it starts to really
connect with
modern day you have the institute of
tropical medicine which was
effectively built from king leopold's
operation in the congo a lot of the
researchers
and students from the institute of
tropical medicine
were graduating and moving on and
joining
particularly one pharmaceutical company
that was a belgian pharmaceutical
company that was down the road
from the institute of tropical medicine
this pharmaceutical company was called
janssen and as
researchers from the institute of
tropical medicine joined yanson
pharmaceuticals they continued to do
that groundbreaking work around the
world developing many of
the medicines that the who considers
essential medicines vaccines serums
medicines and drugs they continue to do
work in the congo for example
where just recently they developed the
vaccine for ebola in
the congo a belgian doctor was part of
an international team
that was called toyambuku in the heart
of the democratic republic of congo
this is their old stomping grounds where
so much of this understanding
of different viruses and parasites and
diseases
was founded during the king leopold days
but instead of the colonizing efforts of
the early 1900s
now these institutions are actually
doing really good work
and actually saving lots of lives
in 1960 yansen pharmaceutical
which is full of all these institute of
tropical medicine
researchers gets purchased by a new
jersey
company called johnson and johnson made
only by johnson and johnson the most
trusted name in surgical rooms
and yes this pharmaceutical company
johnson
this which is now a division of johnson
johnson was the
actual company that developed the
miracle covid19 vaccine
that is saving the world today today
janssen pharmaceuticals part of
healthcare giant johnson johnson
announced this the chairman of johnson
by the way
is a graduate of the institute of
tropical medicine their long legacy in
the congo
and their focus on scientific research
around tropical diseases
is what gave them the capability to be
able to step up to the task and create a
vaccine
for covet 19. in other words this
led to this led to this led to this
led to the first j dose is expected to
go
into americans arms within 24 to 48
hours
again we think it's really important for
our country in the world okay so i know
this sounds like i'm doing some sort of
like expose on johnson and johnson and
johnson and they're like dark
past i'm not the work that they're doing
today is amazing it is saving so many
lives
the institute of tropical medicine is
like an amazing public health
institution that
does really really useful work for
saving many lives around the world
and yet when you trace back the roots of
why this institution exists and the
original motives for it
they're pretty [ __ ] up
his 23 23-year reign was so brutal
that the population halved while leopold
and his men
amassed huge personal faults what this
story teaches me
is just how impossible it is to find
an institution that wasn't founded
on some bloody dark past the country i
live in
and the democracy that i am proud of is
founded on the blood of stolen people
from another continent
how do i evaluate something that i think
is good when i really understand that
the
backstory behind it is terrible and
bloody and
horrific the fact that a life-saving
game changer vaccine
has a legacy that is based on
a greedy horrific king massacring
a bunch of people in the congo is a
really uncomfortable tension
but if you look close enough it's one
that exists
in nearly everything around us
[Music]
you